you start playing a popular video game
after completing level one you get
excited and move on to the next level
the second level is a little different
from the first one and a bit more
challenging too
but you managed to clear this as well
now
you're excited to play even more and you
jump on to the next level
as you must have guessed this level 2 is
challenging
and more difficult than the previous one
but you somehow
crack it that's great
every time you win you're excited to
play more and play better
and eventually you end up playing a
series of levels
what actually happened here want to know
let's find out
[Music]
the entire scenario is an example of the
domino effect
what do we mean by this in simple words
we can say that
when one event leads to another similar
event
and that event leads to another one and
so on
then such a phenomenon is called the
domino effect
confused don't be let's consider
one more example to understand it better
let's take a series of rectangular
blocks like these
and we place them one after the other
like this
now what would happen if we slightly
push the first block
correct it will hit the second block the
second block will hit the third
and this goes on a slight push
sets off a chain of similar events
this is nothing but the domino effect
simple right now before you draw any
conclusion
let's dig a little deeper hey this is
ganesh here from don't memorize
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
don't you think that each block was
dependent on the previous one to fall
yes this one was dependent on this one
while this one on this one even the
falling of the first block
was dependent on our slight push which
eventually set off a chain of similar
events
thus we see that it was that slight push
from our
end which led to the sequential falling
of the blocks
that is an initial application of energy
helped the first block to fall on the
second one
now the energy gained by the second
block helped the third block to fall
and the process continued till the last
block fell
so can we say that all the blocks were
interconnected
and every event that happened happened
sequentially
yes we can now does this example sound
something like our previous example
it absolutely does both deal with the
chain of similar events being set off
so why do you think knowing domino
effect is so important for us
that's because the concept of domino
effect can be applied in different areas
startling isn't it let's have a look at
how we experience the domino effect
in our daily lives let's consider the
prices of petroleum products
tell me one thing who decides the price
of petroleum products
if you say it's the government then
you're not completely wrong
but the involvement of government comes
at a later stage
it actually begins with a body named the
organization of petroleum exporting
countries
it's estimated that around 40 of the
petroleum products
are exported to the rest of the world by
this very body
so for whatever reason if opec decides
to fluctuate the prices of petroleum
products
then the other countries that depend on
it will have to transact money
in accordance with the fluctuation that
means
whatever the alterations be favorable or
unfavorable the government of the
countries that import petroleum products
will obviously react to it and transact
accordingly taking into consideration
the other factors too
like import duty and so on the
government will set the prices of these
products
ultimately the consumers will have to
pay the price that's decided by the
government this
eventually affects the pocket of the
consumers
sometimes positively and sometimes
negatively
through a series of interconnected
activities
this entire scenario can be summarized
like this
let's consider another example and get
the domino effect etched in our minds
forever
imagine a situation where an automobile
industry
is suffering from a crisis it could be
presented like this
the decline in the sales of existing
vehicles in the market
led to the decrease in the revenues as
the revenue's nose dived
it became very difficult for the
industry to operate
thus the production of new vehicles
dropped
further the laborers or the employees
who were involved in the production of
the vehicles
had to lose their jobs due to a plunge
in the same
this signifies the domino effect but on
the other hand
if the sales of the vehicles soar then
consequently
the employment opportunities will again
shoot up
so in general we can state that the
domino effect can either have a positive
or a negative consequence depending on
the situation
now tell me can we apply the domino
effect
on an individual level say we have to
form
a chain of good habits how can we
approach this sequentially
using the domino effect
what's your take on this this is your q
box to explore
let us know your interesting answers in
the comment section below
do subscribe to our channel to be a part
of a massive learning community
happy learning
[Music]